welcome today we're gonna witness a
miracle the miracle of childbirth God
what - do you were discretion is advice
please don't sue me or flag this video
thank you are you expecting soon yes so
what better way to prepare than a flash
game so if you're pregnant right now
please pay close that's the face that is
the face you make Oh early oh god I
don't care just get into the game the
patient today is in her late 20s and is
in pretty good health
pretty good health she looks like she
has rabies mmm-hmm whoa our patients
water just broke
that's the face you make when your water
breaks wait wait wait what am i homicide
what was that what was that okay okay
okay ah yeah I was looking at uh uh oh
Jesus it just falls out what is all that
kill it ah why would anyone want to have
a baby
where do i clamp it or that is a nasty
it's a shady boy Oh nurses Wilson off
the baby but we're not done yet no
please nice haircut oh oh sorry
okay let's do it let's do a couple more
surgeries is this alright here we are at
virtua hip replacement scrub those hands
and grab a retractor all right let's do
this Bruce ah yeah look at is look at a
know we can wipe that ass man I love
being a doctor just wiping ass all day
that's that's what I've been wanting to
do now we fan that ass now we fan that
is now we fame badass alright this could
be gross let's just deal with it like ah
that wasn't too bad there sir
there's an ass inside the ass
what am i listening with a toilet-paper
these games all they make me want to do
is never ever get hurt so I'll never
have to do surgery now we give him some
potato chips I would assume that that's
yeah it's potato potato chip with dip
that's my favorite and now we give
toilet paper there you go nice and shiny
ass I'm sorry man but if my baby looked
like that I would not be smiling like
that I am giving her the galaxy
continuum transfunctioner yes of course
and now I will give her the fabulous
knife of death and suffering and I will
give her the spirit of dead children oh
she's skinny now that's great she was is
really fat let's click save and now I
have my new desktop wallpaper free games
casual why why oh why God why what did
you do to your [ __ ] legs
Britney needs help her legs looks very
bad well [ __ ] me you're right
I'll see what I can do I'm not a [ __ ]
wizard alright we're sucking out fat
from her [ __ ] legs alright you know
what [ __ ] this life is too short I'm
sorry I want a really really really
really good serious [ __ ] surgery game
it's like too much to ask
all right polka muscle this is the game
quadriceps I don't I think I want this
is the highest rated one so it has to be
good right
Mitchell's are typically set several
days Jesus Christ do I have to look at
that [ __ ] haircut and that looks like
a face hey I had a fiducials placed
where they are uh let's see here because
it looks like a smiling I again
um you can put them on I would be wrong
uh you don't to shave as much am not
quite all right now good job thank you
uh first aid electric shock the she was
babysitting watching nothing nothing at
all and the baby got [ __ ] shocked no
Timmy Timmy Oh Timmy's dad Jamie is
[ __ ] dead
ah she died you want me to do is get the
baseball bat and smash Timmy to pieces
yes let's do dad
Oh or that damn it alright now it's our
chance to really [ __ ] him up
alright he's still breathing so we
didn't need to kill him damn it blondie
you can't choke it with your fingers
oh I'll take all your side uh let's
let's twist this Nick come on Timmy
god damn it Tim it alright so I don't
want to be cruel or mean but anyone who
wears orange pants like those needs to
die Fashion Police needs to kill Timmy
Oh mo said yes yes no I won no I won
joke's on you game I [ __ ] won I won
guy why he's dead
if Tim is about to die do the dance do
the dance dancing us ha and with the
pants you have a severe case of the
vagina hand
I can put tattoos on scooby-doo I can
put [ __ ] tattoos but a blue hair
sonic penis on scooby-doo no now scoop
what are you doing
Scoob now god damn it goomy Oh what is
this share the pony ah
I suck yo click belly honey you do daddy
don't spread your legs for me like that
oh no bunny now aah
come on bunny you got a limp laughs God
get it when you lose surgery let's get
the racer shave that chick is Beth Lee
ha ha aah
as a mom tattoo give me shave his face I
always wanted to shave someone's scalpel
Oh
got what what is inside you what am i
doing okay we take the mouse pointer out
for some [ __ ] reason and we put in
some drugs give it give them drugs he
wrap drugs and he's on drugs
what
don't ever get hurt don't ever go
outside because you might get hurt stay
home play video games and and and and
uh-huh
all right thank you for watching buzz
stay awesome this is how Satan was born
I don't know why Taylor Swift keeps show
popping up in my head there's something
that needs to be done oh my god I've
created Satan how did this happen